[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
und nabend gebete heute im bundestag
auch tränen und das wissen es wird nicht
mehr so viele gedenktage geben an dem
zeit zeugen noch selbst berichten können
das könnte jenen in die hände spielen
die mit der geschichte abschließen
wollen oder schlimmer noch sie für ihre
zwecke missbrauchen oder gar um
schreiben wollen nichts ist jedenfalls
so eindringlich wie ein mensch der von
eigenen erlebnissen erzählt überlebende
der shoa wie die inzwischen über 100
jahre alte margot friedländer oder die
87 jährige inge auerbacher die heute im
bundestag sprach sind deshalb ja auch
immer wieder in schulen gegangen zu
jungen menschen weil es beim erinnern
nicht nur um die vergangenheit geht
sondern genauso um das heute und morgen
frank buchwald berichtet vom gedenken im
bundestag
[Musik]
die musiker sind aus prag die musik ist
es auch ein trio von hans krása der
jüdische komponist wurde ermordet
1944 in auschwitz
das deutsche vernichtungslager befreit
vor 77 jahren der bundestag gedenkt der
toten und der überlebenden eine mahnung
sagt präsidentin bärbel bas der
antisemitismus ist da er findet sich
nicht nur am äußersten rand nicht nur
bei den ewig unbelehrbaren und ein paar
antisemitischen trollen im netz er ist
ein problem unserer gesellschaft der
ganzen gesellschaft der antisemitismus
ist mitten unter uns dann spricht inge
auerbacher geboren 1934 in baden
judenhass ist in vielen ländern der welt
auch in deutschland wieder alltäglich
diese krankheit muss so schnell wie
möglich
geheilt werden
auerbacher überlebte als kind im
konzentrationslager theresienstadt
unser spiel war ein v riechender
abfallhaufen hier rücken wir stundenlang
herum und hofften einen schatz zu finden
halb verfaulte rüben und
kartoffelschalen bei denen man noch
einen essbaren schlitz abschneiden
konnte
ihre freundin im lager ein mädchen aus
berlin
ruth mitnahmen
ruden ich waren die schwestern und wir
versprachen uns
gegenseitig zu besuchen sie nach
jebenhausen und ich nach berlin
li beruht
ich bin hier in berlin um dich zu
besuchen
roth und ihre eltern wurden ermordet in
einer der gaskammern in auschwitz
tief berührt auch mickey levy präsident
des israelischen parlament der knesset
erinnerungsarbeit verbindet unsere
beiden völker das israelische und das
deutsche es ist uns aber gelungen uns
aus dem nationalen historischen trauma
zu erheben und etwas neues zu schaffen
zum schluss rezitiert levy das jüdische
totengebet kaddisch er liest aus dem
gebetbuch eines jüdischen jungen aus
deutschland auch er opfer der shoah
die zuschauer berührt und ergriffen
selten so was im bundestag
eine woche ist es her dass das
missbrauchs gutachten für das erzbistum
münchen und freising veröffentlicht
wurde mit all den wellen die das schlug
und die bis in die vatikanstadt
schwappten zu einem zurückgetretenen
papst dessen umgang mit diesen
erschütterungen selbst von wohlmeinenden
als glücklich empfunden wurde heute nun
hat sich in münchen kardinal marx
geäußert barbara lukat sein auftritt
beobachtet
die wut ist riesig und sie bleibt
deutliche botschaften heute morgen vor
der stellungnahme des erzbischofs der
nächtliche schriftzug wurde von der
katholischen akademie ganz bewusst nicht
übertüncht dort tritt kardinal marx
heute kurz vor 11 uhr die kameras er
zeigt sich zweifelnd und kämpferisch und
immer wieder demütig seine zentrale
botschaft benennt er klar dass für mich
die größte schuld darin besteht die
betroffenen übersehen zu haben
das ist unverzeihlich dass
missbrauchs gutachten letzte woche war
für das erzbistum vernichtend
ausgefallen
auf den akteuren liegt schwere schuld
doch marx vorgänger kardinal wetter und
der spätere papst benedikt winden sich
zwischen glaube und glaubwürdigkeit
scheinen inzwischen welten zu liegen
marx versucht heute den weg nach vorn
ich war und bin ich gleich politik
hätte ich noch mehr und engagierte
handeln können sicher ja es gibt keine
zukunft des christentums in unserem land
ohne eine erneuerte kirche
betroffenen verbänden und der
reformbewegung wir sind kirche aber ist
das alles nicht genug sie wollen sie
brauchen taten jetzt geht es nicht mehr
ums reden sondern er muss jetzt wirklich
in seinem bistum und in der deutschen
bischofskonferenz und weltweit er muss
wirklich jetzt wieder der starke mann
sein der sich für reformen einsetzen
gibt es kein zurück mehr
doch ist marx dafür noch der richtige
betroffene ungläubige zweifeln und
verzweifeln
die zahl der kirchenaustritte steigt
dramatisch
und die stimmen die im sinne der
aufklärung politik und staat einfordern
werden immer lauter weil es die kirche
selbst nicht schafft der münchner
pfarrer schießler wittert in dieser
erosion hingegen eine historische chance
für erneuerung und lang ersehnte
veränderung jetzt merken wir ja da
bricht ja was zusammen diese ganzen
männer bündnisse dieses ganze
starken system bricht in sich zusammen
niemand muss jetzt mehr angst vor haben
dass es hier nach oben beendet er zur
freude ihr liegt hier völlig falsch
vielleicht sprach kardinal marx heute
auch deshalb noch diese worte als
erzbischof trage ich nach meiner
moralischen überzeugung und in meinem
amtsverständnis verantwortung für das
handeln des erzbistums
ich klebe nicht an meinem amt
und während diese tage eine kirche am
boden spiegeln melden sich im münchner
erzbistum weitere opfer sexuellen
missbrauchs
das wollen wir mit unserem münchner
korrespondenten noch mal näher
beleuchten stefan leifert wenn man sich
von diesen bekenntnissen heute einen
befreiungsschlag erhofft ist das
gelungen
also wenn dieser tag heute 1 gezeigt hat
dann dass diese kategorie
befreiungsschlag für die kirche
eigentlich nicht mehr existiert denn das
repertoire an gesten und worten das hat
sich mittlerweile einfach erschöpft was
die worte angeht man nahm dem kardinal
das heute durchaus ab seine reue auch
seine entschuldigung das sagen auch
seine kritiker das war durchaus
authentisch aber all das kommt aus sicht
vieler opfer einfach zu spät und diese
worte treffen auf eine kirchenbasis die
ihre entscheidung zu einem großen teil
längst getroffen hat auch hier in
münchen haben sich die
kirchenaustrittszahlen binnen einer
woche verdoppelt teilweise sogar
verdreifacht und da gehen teilweise die
treusten der treuen also diese
kernschmelze ist auch hier längst im
gange und was die geste eines
amtsverzichts angeht diese geste hat
sich verbraucht im letzten sommer als
der kardinal seinen rücktritt ja bereits
angeboten hat und der papst das ganze
dann abgelehnt hat dass er nicht am amt
klebt wie er heute sagt auch das war
durchaus authentisch und nimmt man ihm
ab aber kardinal marx hat heute auch
nicht so richtig deutlich machen können
was er in seinem amt und mit seinem amt
eigentlich noch bewirken kann das
versprechen auf reformen hat er gemacht
denn das hört man dann ja auch immer
wieder was ist daran überhaupt noch
realistisch
diese reform oder die einlösung dieser
reformversprechen ist vielleicht die
einzige chance die die kirche noch hätte
um den erosionsprozess zu stoppen aber
auch hier ist die gefahr groß dass große
hoffnungen im ganz großen stil
enttäuscht werden denn die ganzen
klassiker dieser reform themen
frauenpriestertums sexualmoral zölibat
oder abschaffung des zölibats all diese
themen werden nicht in deutschland
sondern auf welt kirchen ebene
entschieden und haben dort keine
mehrheit marginal marx sind zwischen
auch ein frontmann der reformer in
deutschland geworden sein innerhalb der
deutschen bischofskonferenz weht ihm
aber von einem lauten von einem
lautstarken aber nicht besonders großen
flügel auch eisiger wind entgegen also
auch die bischofskonferenz ist ihr tief
gespalten dankeschön stefan die
einschätzungen und nachher im heute
schon mal update gibt es dazu noch ein
gespräch mit dem kirchenrechtler thomas
schiller
die korona pandemie feiert bezogen auf
deutschland heute eine art trauriges
jubiläum vor exakt zwei jahren wurde
hierzulande der erste corona fall
diagnostiziert der mitarbeiter eines
autozulieferers hatte sich bei einer aus
china angereisten kollegen angesteckt
manchmal ist ja gut dass man nicht schon
im vorhinein weiß was dann so alles auf
einen zukommt und wie lange es dauert
die zahlen heute mehr als 200.000
gemeldeten neuinfektionen die inzidenz
klettert über 1000 und es gibt
188 neue todesfälle die aktuellen
spitzenplätze man infektionsgeschehen
belegt die hauptstadt mit gleich
mehreren bezirken ganz berlin ist längst
von omikron erobert doch ein gewisser
maßen unbeugsames gesundheitsamt im
bezirk treptow-köpenick dennoch nicht
auf dem eindringen wieder eindringlinge
widerstand leisten zu wollen zumindest
administrativ versucht man dort noch
manches was anderswo schon ganz
aufgegeben wurde eindrücke aus berlin
fahren kasten während
gesundheitsamt republik schönen guten
tag sie dürfen mir jetzt jürgen ihre
fragen stellen gesundheitsamt
treptow-köpenick die korona hotline des
bezirks die mitarbeiter im fragen
gewitter okay wie sieht's aus dem magen
durchfall oder übelkeit
keine geruchs geschmacks bewusst mann
wurde dann der pcr fertiggemacht mehr
hinten in der warteschleife
exponentielles wachstum 700 anrufe pro
tag die kontakt verfolgung haben sie
eingestellt stattdessen setzen sie auf
erreichbarkeit betreuung von
risikogruppen und eigene impfaktionen
das corona team des außenbezirks wurde
mehrfach aufgestockt jetzt sind sie 70
männer und frauen stark die meisten
neuen sind quereinsteiger pandemie
koordinator keiko was ist eigentlich dj
seine kollegin war flugbegleiterin
eigentlich braucht man immer einen
großen bogen um so ämter gerade sehr
ständiger ich glaube dadurch dass ja
diese ganze pandemie und auch die ganze
corona geschichte leute zusammengeführt
hat die vorher nie zusammengeführt
worden wären ja hat das hier wirklich zu
einer störung geführt sie haben das amt
verändert vor einem jahr musste die
bundeswehr helfen die akten stapelten
sich jetzt sind sie strukturiert
modernisiert digitalisiert und haben
doch noch das berühmt berüchtigte
faxgerät
wirklich mal angefangen mit alles auf
papier und wir sind ja mittlerweile
komplett digital ist auch ein fax von
über 70 mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
momentan bringt omikron auch die
digitale verfassung an ihre grenzen im
posteingang warten 3046 meldungen von
corona laboren
tagesaktuell
versuchen unser bestes tag für tag fall
für fall aber
das ist einfach von einer masse herum zu
schaffen nicht nur hier in ganz berlin
ist rückstau fast 30.000 fälle das heißt
die inzidenz in der hauptstadt ist
eigentlich noch höher als die aktuellen
rekordwerte
rückstau verzögert auch den versand der
quarantäne bescheide an die bürger die
verschickt das papierlose abend übrigens
nicht per e mail sondern per brief auf
papier liebevoll per hand gefaltet die
neue falzmaschine will einfach nicht so
falten dass es passt
das enthält sich klein machen die uns
jeden tag beschäftigen das ist immer wie
eine wundertüte
einmal durchatmen dann packen sie wieder
an damit corona bald ein ende hat und dj
kowarsch eine party veranstalten kann
für seine kollegen vom gesundheitsamt
ich hab mal sehen was zuerst kommt der
party oder eine funktionierende
falzmaschine der wahl england und
dänemark das ja eine sehr hohe impfquote
hat jetzt wieder lockern damit beging
nachrichten heinz ja in dänemark
kündigte die regierung die lockerungen
ab dem ersten februar an zu müssen dann
an den meisten orten keine masken mehr
getragen oder impfnachweis gezeigt
werden in england sind die meisten
corinna beschränkungen bereits heute
aufgehoben worden damit entfällt die
masken pflicht auch in den meisten
innenräumen in london allerdings gilt im
öffentlichen nahverkehr weiterhin masken
pflicht in clubs und bei
großveranstaltungen sind im pfund test
nachweise nicht mehr vorgeschrieben
der bundestag hat einen umstrittenen
nachtragshaushalt für 2021 gebilligt
ursprünglich waren die kredite für
kosten der korona pandemie vorgesehen
wurden aber nicht abgerufen die 60
milliarden euro sollen in den kommenden
jahren für klimaschutz energiewende und
digitalisierung ausgegeben werden die
union hält diese umschichtung für
verfassungswidrig und will klage
einreichen
am obersten gericht der usa steht im
sommer ein wechsel bevor wie
us-präsident beiden heute bestätigte
werde sich der 83-jährige richter
stephen breyer von seinem amt am supreme
court zurückziehen als nachfolgerin will
beiden nun erstmals in der us-geschichte
eine schwarze frau nominieren beiden
bekommt zum ersten mal in seiner
amtszeit die möglichkeit einen der neuen
höchst einflussreichen sitze an dem
gericht nachzubesetzen
in italien hat auch die vierte
abstimmung bei der präsidentenwahl zu
keiner entscheidung geführt erneut
enthielt sich mehr als die hälfte der
wahlfrauen und männer so dass niemand
die erforderliche absolute mehrheit
erreichte auch nicht der als favorit
gehandelte ministerpräsident draghi und
damit geht die suche nach einem neuen
staatsoberhaupt morgen weiter
er und dann wurde am abend noch eine
interessante politische personalie in
berlin bekannt cdu fraktionschef ralph
brinkhaus räumt das feld was dann
künftig auch von friedrich merz
beschreibt bestellt wird mitgeteilt hat
brinkhaus seinen rückzug für einem brief
an die unionsfraktion
als der frisch gebackene parteichef märz
nicht vorhatte den wichtigsten posten im
parlament einem anderen zu überlassen
daran gab es ja auch wenig zweifel theo
jedenfalls seit friedrich merz am
vergangenen wochenende mit fast 95
prozent zum parteivorsitzenden gewählt
worden war spätestens da war klar dass
ralph brinkhaus sich den parteichef
nicht würde widersetzen können und
offensichtlich hat ihnen dann auch noch
der csu chef markus söder die märz karte
gezeigt und dann war klar das brinkhaus
keine chance mehr hat theoretisch hätte
er sich zwar noch bis ende april halten
können so lange ist er ja gewählt aber
das hätte dann drei wichtige
landtagswahlen überschattet und die
union wollte auf jeden fall einen
weiteren internen machtkampf vermeiden
davon hatte sie ja nun auch nach
diversen konkurrenzkämpfen um den
cdu-vorsitz und nach dem 10 gerangel
zwischen söder und laschet um die
kanzlerkandidatur wahrlich genug
kurioserweise hat übrigens vor genau 20
jahren angela merkel dasselbe mit märz
gemacht und ihm aus den fraktionsvorsitz
gedrängt damals wie heute gehört zu den
ungeschriebenen grundregeln der
politischen macht struktur dass ein
oppositionsführer erst dann
schlagkräftig ist wenn der partei- und
fraktionsvorsitz inne hat erst dann hat
er für die politische auseinandersetzung
mit der regierung die nötige politische
sichtbarkeit und ab mitte februar wird
das jetzt für friedrich merz der fall
sein dankeschön für die analyse aus
berlin theo koll er hatte den bundestag
dem friedrich merz nunmehr also der
uneingeschränkt führende
oppositionsredner sein wird ging es
heute um die ukraine frage wer redet
schießt nicht ist dabei der satz mit dem
außenministerium borg am häufigsten
zitiert wird an dem satz kann auf den
ersten blick natürlich nichts falsch
sein auf den zweiten blick fällt auf
dass es sehr wohl konflikte gibt bei
denen gleichzeitig geredet und
geschossen wird der konflikt in der ost
ukraine etwa wäre dafür ein beispiel
dieser seit jahren ungelöste frozen
konflikt mit einem waffenstillstand der
regelmäßig gebrochen wird und
das ist das nächste problem wie man
miteinander redet aus welcher position
heraus kann sehr damit zusammenhängen
wie gut man schießen könnte und ob sich
da einer viel stärker fühlt als der
andere das alles weiß natürlich auch die
ministerin aber das dilemma der
deutschen außenpolitik kann sie nicht
lösen wie uneinig man sich quer durch
alle parteien ist zeigte sich heute auch
im bundestag klaus brodbeck berichtet
der kanzler ist da durchaus der
regierung spricht nur die
aussenministerin annalena baerbock lobt
gemeinsame gespräche russlands und der
ukraine
die gestern unter deutscher und
französischer begleitung wieder
aufgenommen wurden
ob da was bei rauskommt wir wissen es
nicht niemand kann das in dieser zeit
hundertprozentig sagen aber wer redet
der schießt nicht zuhört auch der
botschafter der ukraine offensichtlich
unterwegs mit deutschem vehikel gestern
hat ja auch deutsche waffen für sein
land gefordert die bundesregierung droht
stattdessen moskau mit sanktionen
neuer aggression steht die krankheit
unserer antworten zur verfügung
inklusive nur aus dem 2 ja wir wollen
jederzeit dialog aber es braucht
angesichts der aktuellen lage auch härte
scholz schweigen kritisiert friedrich
merz demnächst vorsitzende der cdu und
vorgeschmack auch oppositionsführer
es kann sein dass wir noch etwas zeit
haben aber dann mehr bundeskanzler darf
an der europäischen und dann darf auch
an der deutschen entschlossenheit kein
zweifel entstehen und diese zweifel sind
da und das ist ihre verantwortung herr
bundeskanzler das ist ihre politik sie
führen nicht der spd vorsitzende hält
dagegen lars klingbeil greift märz an
der davor gewarnt hatte russland aus dem
weltweiten zahlungssystem swift
auszuschließen es war nicht der
vorsitzende der fdp oder die
vorsitzenden der grünen oder der spd die
als erstes gerufen haben die aber es
wirft neben wir raus das waren sie haben
der russischen seite gezeigt dass wir
dort wackeln an dieser stelle ich habe
um im bild zu bleiben was ich gewählt
habe auf die sprengkraft hingewiesen die
eine aussetzung von swift bedeuten würde
aber es liegt auch für mich ausdrücklich
mit auf dem tisch russlands
truppenaufmarsch an der grenze zur
ukraine gefährde den frieden in europa
warnt die fdp die russische seite wäre
erheblich glaubwürdiger wenn präsident
putin den rückzug dieser truppe norden
wird doch es gibt auch unterstützung für
moskau von den politischen rändern bei
der verhandlung muss man auch moskau
entgegenkommen sonst machen kann gar
keinen sinn man muss ja nicht alles
übernehmen aber man muss entgegenkommen
und die bereitschaft zu zeigen es gibt
keinen krieg ist droht auch kein krieg
es droht kein gas mangel die
sicherheitsinteressen russlands müssen
wir ernst nehmen dann klappt das auch
mit dem weltfrieden wenn scholz
verhandelt dann ungern öffentlich offen
ob das sein schweigen erklärt
in jedem fall wird deutschland weiter
unter druck kommen sowohl bei der
zulassung von waffenexporten als auch
bei nordstream 2 russland wiederum hat
heute auf die abgestimmten briefe aus
amerika und vom nato-hauptquartier
reagiert bemerkenswert zögerlich selbst
außenminister lavrov sonst nie um einen
harten verbalen schlag verlegen hielt
sich eher zurück tenor des kreml herr
putin lese das jetzt erstmal in ruhe und
wir schauen derweil in die ukraine
unsere reporterin anna feist ist
weitergereist von don was mit seinen
russischen separatisten hinunter an die
grenze zu annektierten krim und
schildert ihre eindrücke
die grenzkontrollstelle schon gar hier
beginnt die krim die ukrainische
halbinsel die 2014 von russland
annektiert wurde der checkpoint wirkt an
diesem mittag fast verwaist dabei steht
die krim wieder im fokus denn der
ukrainische geheimdienst mutmaßt putin
könnte von hier aus angreifen und so
eine landverbindung zur russischen
grenze schaffen für ukrainerin marija
eine angespannte reise zu ihrem vater
auf die krim
ich habe angst ich weiß nicht was hier
passieren wird es ist ungewiss
den ukrainischen grenze barista dagegen
lassen die militärischen manöver der
russen scheinbar unbeeindruckt
was wollen die hier schon holen hier
gibt es ja nichts
aljona auf wochenend besucht seit vier
uhr morgens ist die russin von der krim
unterwegs um ihrem 14 jährigen sohn zu
besuchen wer hat die ukrainische
staatsbürgerschaft deshalb darf der seit
2014 seit der annexion nicht mehr im
haus seiner eltern auf der krim leben
sondern ist bei der tante in der ukraine
hinter gekommen aljona macht das wütend
schuld habe die ukraine als ich das
letzte mal die grenze passierte sagten
die ukrainischen grenze zu mir wartet
mal ab wir werden die krim zurückerobern
also ist die ukraine der aggressor nach
russland auf jeden fall nicht 1 trennte
aljona und ihre ukrainische schwägerin
irina nur ein 40-minütiger fußweg heute
eine landesgrenze mit stundenlanger
umfahrung die ursache des ganzen übels
sei die beiden revolution vor acht
jahren gewesen als die bevölkerung der
pro russischen regierung in der ukraine
das vertrauen entzog
nun wenn damals 2014 der ehemalige
präsident einfach die armee mobilisiert
hätte dann wäre das alles nicht so
ausgeartet da gab es doch keine helden
auf dem majdan
und heute eine anspannung durch
russische militärmanöver spüren die
frauen hier nicht im gegenteil ich
wohne 20 kilometer von der grenze
entfernt und habe da keinen einzigen
russischen soldaten gesehen da ist
nichts woher habt ihr das ich muss doch
wissen ich wohne doch hier
wir sitzen hier völlig entspannt es gibt
hier keine armee leute mein cousin rief
mich neulich an und sagte nimm die
kinder und farin die west ukraine
ich fragte ihn warum er sagte bei euch
gibt es doch panzer und sowas aber hier
ist nichts keine panzer keine armee bei
uns ist alles ruhig
ob propaganda ihre ansichten prägt
können wir nicht verifizieren doch an
der grenze zur krim scheinen sich
insbesondere die russischstämmigen
einwohner noch in sicherheit zu wiegen
und
jetzt nochmals volk zunächst mit dem
blick auf die finanzwelt da gehörte die
deutsche bank heute zu den top themen
insbesondere die zahlen die deutschlands
größtes geldhaus vorgelegt hat kommt man
wie steht die deutsche bank aktuell dar
naja vorstandschef seewegen konnte der
öffentlichkeit heute einen milliarden
gewinn präsentieren nach einem
minigewinn 2020 nun das beste ergebnis
seit zehn jahren in der zwischenzeit
hatte es zuweilen herbe verluste und
unrühmliche skandale gegeben konkret
konnte das geldhaus dieses mal vor
steuern 3,4 milliarden euro verdienen
nach steuern und dem abzug von
zinszahlungen bleiben 1,9 milliarden das
investmentbanking bringt nach wie vor
das meiste geld das geschäft mit
währungen und anleihen brummt in der
pandemie zudem trägt der radikale umbau
erste früchte tausende stellen wurden
abgebaut ganze geschäftsbereiche
aufgegeben die aktie kann heute kräftig
zulegen deutlich über vier prozent
doch noch bleiben analysten skeptisch
das grundproblem der deutschen bank wie
auch von anderen banken ist dass die
umsätze gleich bleiben oder auch sinken
aber der kostenblock zu hoch ist von
daher muss man die kosten noch besser in
griff bekommt gerade auch bei der
deutschen bank ob der heute
veröffentlichte milliarden-gewinn die
trendwende war oder doch nur eine
eintagsfliege wird sich also erst noch
zeigen müssen frank bethmann dank
facebook nutzer die sich vor einer
änderung der nutzungsbedingungen ende
mai 2018 registriert haben dürfen
weiterhin pseudonyme verwenden eine
klarnamen pflicht sei in bestimmten
fällen unwirksam das entschied heute der
bundesgerichtshof er gab damit zwei
nutzern überwiegend recht deren mit
fantasienamen genutzten facebook konten
gesperrt worden waren das urteil bezieht
sich auf accounts die vor inkrafttreten
von neuen eu-regeln angelegt worden
waren in den aktuellen
nutzungsbedingungen verpflichtet
facebook seine user den echten namen
anzugeben damit sollen hass und mobbing
gestoppt werden
in gut einer woche beginnen die
winterspiele in peking jetzt sind die
olympischen dörfer offiziell eröffnet
worden unter strengen vorsichtsmaßnahmen
wegen der korona pandemie
ohne pomp die offizielle einweihung der
dörfer zu den einrichtungen an den drei
wettkampf hatten gehören auch modernste
jims und science fiction wie diese
hightech cantine die solche
köstlichkeiten auf tischen die ersten
athleten haben ihre quartiere schon
bezogen und das ioc behauptet
die athleten sind sehr froh hier in
peking die spiele zu zelebrieren das
werden außergewöhnlich sichere spiele
corona vorsichtsmaßnahmen mit helfern in
sicherheitskleidung kontakt soll
vermieden werden tägliche test gehören
zur routine in dem hochhaus dörfern die
hermetisch abgeriegelt sind wohl weniger
zum wohl der athletin sondern als
schutzwall für china
das war es von uns bei maybrit illner
geht es gleich weiter sie debattiert
heute unter dem titel streit ums testen
und impfen wieder nicht gemeinsam gegen
korona und um 0.30 gibt's dann unser
heute schon ein update bitten alle
optimiert und hier erwarten sie ab
morgen christian sievers in hanna
zimmermann auf wiedersehen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter dieses tiefe das
hat uns schon heute regen gebracht und
schnee in den höheren lagen das ganze
mit diesen fronten ihres verlagert sich
allmählich nach südosten aber das
nächste tief steht bereit und kommt dann
zum wochenende zu uns bringt sehr viel
wind teils mit orkanartigen böen schauen
erst die kommende nacht und da wird es
im südosten glatt werden mit regen und
schnee das ganze verlagert sich nach
südosten sonst lockert teilweise auf
aber ganz im norden ist es stürmisch
teils mit sturmböen temperaturen sinken
dazu auf minus vier grad an den alpen
und plus vier grad an der see morgen im
tagesverlauf ziehen sich die wolken
weiter nach südosten regen und schnee
weiter bis nach bayern ansonsten lockert
es auf die sonne zeigt sich häufiger als
in den tagen zuvor und das bei höchsten
temperaturen von einem grad am alpenrand
und 8 grad im westen deutschlands
die nächsten tage werden sehr turbulent
werden am samstag erreicht uns dieses
sturmtief und vor allem in der nacht auf
sonntag sind teilweise sogar orkanartige
böen möglich dazu gibt es regen die
temperaturen steigen am samstag auf vier
bis elf grad und auch am sonntag ist es
immer noch sehr sehr windig am vormittag
immer noch orkanartige böen möglich und
das bei meist sonnigem wetter zumindest
im norden damit wünsche ich ihnen ein
schöner abend